here's a Giant Pacific octopus in an
equally giant aquarium tank okay that's
all great for mom and dad and the whole
family who come to see the octopus
except there are sharks in this tank as
well sharks that are voracious predators
and opportunistic feeders and that have
been known to veer from their usual
fishy diets to munch on an occasional
octopus these are spiny dogfish sharks
did anybody ask the octopus about this
[Music]
what the aquarium folks are thinking is
that the octopus can use its ability to
camouflage itself as protection and if
that doesn't work it has the strength to
fight off the shark or at least dash to
the nearest hiding hole that can squeeze
into the aquarium folks soon realize
what does happen when you put these
sharks and octopi in the same tank and
you're about to see it too
if you've got the courage to keep
watching if only through your splayed
fingers the octopus not in the habit of
attacking sharks the shark sharp spines
jutting up from its dorsal fins that can
puncture anything that touches them the
octopus can its powers of defense save
it in such tight quarters the shark
menacing on the prowl just itching to
use those rows of teeth to crush its
next meal I've got a feeling this
real-life version of Jaws isn't going to
be pretty and so the shark
the shark boy am I glad I didn't have a
bet down on this match oh that's right
this is what happened the Giant Pacific
octopus as seen here in this amazing so
close you feel like you might get
squashed footage was making short work
of the shark in the tank
[Music]
dogfish carcasses kept showing up at the
bottom of the tank what you're seeing
this footage was taken to see what was
doing in these supposedly invincible
predators the aquarium staff learned
something new about the octopi there was
a danger in the tank all right but it
was all to the Sharks
[Music]
that's one way to defend yourself from a
predator eliminate them